hello again we have another batch of the
worst woke religion tick tocks this is
my least favorite category of tick tock
even more than the weird people jiggling
around and the groomers preaching all
sorts of sex stuff to kids so without
further ado
let's take it away one of the things
that pushed me off of Christianity
initially was how unchristian most
Christians are the Republican party or
evangelicals in general resemble far
more the Pharisees in the Bible than
Jesus themselves like that is like
probably the most consistent theme that
I've seen throughout all of my
experience with Christian communities in
the United States almost ubiquitously
these would be the same type like if
Jesus came back today like I think that
the average Evangelical would call him a
loser Progressive hippie that was like
being too soft on poor people like 100
percent uh yeah there might be some
truth to that I think the argument you
know you Christians you're the you're
the worst example of your religion I
love the Christianity but I don't love
the Christians here or whatever it's
really trite nonsense that is just kind
of a cope I think for atheists who don't
want to deal seriously with religion or
their spiritual life but he's got
something of a point he's not naming
exactly which denominations or sects or
Breakaway groups there are a lot of
mistaken conceptions of Christianity in
the United States modern
1980s style American capitalism that's
the ideal of Christian Life no I don't
think it's quite that I mean the word
capitalism by the way was popularized by
Karl Marx so no obviously not this
problem that America suffers from right
now is that Christianity does not
suffuse enough of the American Spirit
America was founded as a Christian
Nation by all of the men who founded it
going all the way back to 1620 in the
Mayflower 1630 Governor John Winthrop
shiny City on a Hill model of Christian
charity going up to 1776 and the
Constitution John Adams saying that the
principles which United the fathers of
the country were the general principles
of Christianity agreed upon by every
sect so it's a Christian Nation there's
no question about that but Christianity
has has waned in public life and certain
people especially those who have a kind
of corrupted understanding and practice
of the faith are grasping and are
wanting that's true it might not even
necessarily be their faults they might
sincerely be missing some part of the
picture here that's really should work
on that I sort of agree you know big
Tech is more powerful than most
countries are
they profit by exploiting your personal
data it's time to put a layer of
protection between your online activity
and big Tech that's why I use expressvpn
think about how much of your life is on
the internet well unfortunately every
website you visit every video you watch
every message you send gets tracked and
data mined when you run expressvpn on
your device the software hides your IP
address something big Tech can use to
personally identify you so expressvpn
makes your activity harder to trace and
sell to advertisers expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your internet data to
keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers on your network what I
like most about expressvpn is how simple
it is to use download the app on your
phone or computer tap one button and you
are protected expressvpn does all this
without slowing your connection that's
why it's rated the number one VPN
service by techradar The Verge and most
importantly of all Michael Knowles go to
expressvpn.com Michael YT get three
extra months for break okay next one
unpopular opinion God is pro-choice
never in humanity has God stripped us of
our ability to choose we see this in
Genesis chapter 2 when God places Adam
in the midst of the garden and presents
all of his best options to him but does
not remove the most destructive choice
in fact God commands Adam not to eat of
this forbidden tree and does not remove
the ability for him to choose it why is
this significant because God is more
concerned with our desire to choose him
than he is with the legislation of
righteousness so while God may be
grieved at every single abortion he is
equally concerned about the heart
posture of the one who has to choose
okay a very bad argument but I could see
how this lady would fall into it God
gives man Free Will and we see this in
the Garden of Eden When God says don't
eat from the Tree of the knowledge of
Good and Evil but you still have free
will so you have the ability to make
that choice if you so wish and then what
happens Adam and Eve eat the apple and
then what happens God casts them out of
paradise and they from the sweat of
their brow they have to eat their you
know that's how they all sustain their
bodies until they die because sin and
death have pervaded the world now and
things get really really bad really
really quick so yeah there are
consequences to that yes there is a law
in the Garden of Eden there is a
commandment actually God says do not eat
the fruit of that tree
and then Adam breaks that commandment
and then he is punished for that much as
we say okay no abortions because killing
is wrong that's okay Officer I think
they learned murder is wrong people
still have the ability to have an
abortion and then there will be a
punishment for that the fact that people
have free will doesn't mean that they
are free from consequence or punishment
or law especially when we're talking
about murder here she seems to even be
kind of granting
that abortion is pantamount to murder
and she says yeah but even so man has to
have the right to do it no a man doesn't
have the right to do that and in fact
then what's the next crime that we see
in the Bible right after Genesis chapter
2 Adam and Eve's son Cain kills his
brother Abel and then what happens the
blood cries out to God for justice the
Abel's blood from the ground guys that
cries out to God and then his God say
well I'm sorry you know my hands are
tied here because you see Cain had the
choice it's his choice and I'm so
pro-choice and everything uh no actually
God puts a mark on Cain and banishes him
and he has to wander around the earth
until the end of his days I've actually
heard similar arguments made though not
even just by crazy Libs but even by
Libertarians who say well it's just very
important we all have a choice sure you
have choice in as much as you have an
ability that cannot be and you have a
spiritual Freedom as well by the way
even if you're imprisoned and tied up
and on a chained to the wall you still
have this this spiritual ability and
mental ability to think as you will
think and believe as you will believe
but that doesn't mean that you're free
from all restrictions of Civil Society
it doesn't mean that there are there's
no such thing as a civil Authority or
the moral law or right and wrong the
reason that the Civil Authority has
power and why the The Authority has
wields the sword and does not wield it
in vain is because there is a difference
between good and bad and right and wrong
and it is not only the right of the
Civil Authority but the responsibility
to encourage the good stuff and
discourage the bad stuff I hope I have
encouraged those tick talkers I'll tell
you you know I kind of actually didn't
mind those so that the destiny one was a
little bit
trite but I think he was
talking about it sincerely and he had a
point I think he actually had a
something of a fair point and then the
gal at the end made a really really bad
argument but she might have been making
that argument sincerely I mean I've
heard I've heard Libertarians fall into
the same trap as that crazy far left
liberal is that that the very fact that
man has free will implies that man
should be free from all legal or social
constraints which obviously does not
follow and would lead to the complete
destruction of mankind but I could see
how she'd fall into that so hers was the
worst one
but maybe she'll watch this video and be
corrected we'll see you next time
[Music]
sin and death
[Music]